Air is normally an insulator, but under certain
conditions, it can suddenly and temporarily
change into a conductor, and we end up with
a spark. In this video, we'll use the related
concepts of electric fields and electric potential
to explain how insulators can suddenly, dramatically
and temporarily become conductors.
This video is part of the Derivatives and
Integrals video series.
Hello. My name is John McGreevy. I am a professor
in the physics department at MIT, and today
I'll be talking with you about the electric
field and electrical potential.
To get the most out of this video you should
already have some exposure to the electric
field and electric potential. You should be
able to take a mathematical expression for
the field and obtain the potential, and vice
versa. You should also know how to draw equipotential
surfaces and electric field vectors.
Throughout this video our goal is to help
you gain a clearer picture of the electric
field and the electric potential. By the end
of the video you should also be able to describe
the process of electrical breakdown by using
either the field or the potential.
Let's start with a review of electric field
and electric potential. First we'll describe
them conceptually. Then we'll show the mathematical
relationship between them, and show some of
their typical visual representations.
First, let's see what you remember. Take out
a piece of paper and write down everything
you remember about the electric field and
the electric potential. Try to concentrate
on their similarities and differences. Pause
the video to do this.
Now you can compare the list you made to our
list.
The electric field is generated by electric
charges, and extends an infinite distance
from them.
If you bring a second electric charge into
a region of electric field, there will be
a force exerted on it. Like all forces, that
force has magnitude and direction. The stronger
the charge is, the more force will be applied
to it.
The electric field is a vector quantity. It
has a vector value at every point in space,
measured in Newtons per Coulomb or Volts per
Meter.
Much like the electric field, electric potentials
are created by charges and extend an infinite
distance from them.
If you bring a second charge into a region
of electrical potential, that second charge
will gain or lose potential energy. The stronger
that charge, the more its potential energy
will change.
Unlike the electric field, the electric potential
is a scalar quantity, which means that everywhere
you look you can find a number that represents
the potential, measured in Joules per Coulomb.
Let's look at two ways to envision an electric
potential for a positively charged line near
the origin. We're going to look at this in
two dimensions to make things easier to see.
We can also draw the level curves for the
electric potential function. These are called
"equipotential lines," because the value of
the potential is equal at every point on a
given line. For instance, we might draw lines
every ten volts.
If we plot the potential on the vertical axis,
we end up with this mountain-like shape. We
can imagine positive charges rolling down
the mountain as they are pushed away from
our line charge.
We can also sketch the electric field around
a line charge. If we pick regularly spaced
points at which to draw our electric field
vectors, we end up with a picture like this
one. Each vector shows the direction and strength
of the electric field at that point. The longer
the arrow, the stronger the field is. Here
you might imagine the arrows pushing a positive
charge away from our line
Displaying both the equipotential lines and
the field vectors at once, we get this picture.
You can see that the equipotential lines are
always perpendicular to the field.
Since charges create both fields and potentials,
both will be present all the time, though
we might only draw one or the other.
The field and the potential are related mathematically
through the gradient operator. As a vector
operator, the gradient turns the scalar potential
into a vector field. To go in the other direction,
a line integral of the electric field turns
that vector field into the scalar electric
potential.
The negative sign that appears in both equations
is important—the electric field points in
the opposite direction from any changes in
the potential. If the electric potential increases
in a particular direction, the electric field
points in the opposite direction.
We're going to use something called "electrical
breakdown" to illustrate our concepts today.
We'll start with an example, give a definition,
then go into an explanation of the phenomenon.
Here is a clip from the Boston Museum of Science
to demonstrate
the phenomenon.
Quite a dramatic demonstration! Let's look
at this in a little more depth.
Electrical breakdown is defined as the process
by which an insulating material in a strong
electric field becomes electrically conductive.
The material actually changes from being an
insulator to being a conductor. In the clip
you saw, this happened in the air near the
Van de Graaff generator, and a large electric
spark resulted.
You may sometimes hear this referred to as
breakdown potential, or breakdown voltage,
which is the same thing.
The exact value of the electric field needed
depends on many factors, including distance,
humidity, temperature, and the material itself.
Here is a simplified explanation of how electrical
breakdown works in air. Consider this house
in a thunderstorm.
If we zoom in on the air above the house,
we can see the molecules of gas in the air.
Thunderstorms involve strong electric fields
and high electric potential differences. We
can represent those on our diagram.
Imagine that one electron is pulled from its
atom by the strong electric field. Because
the electron is negatively charged, it will
accelerate against the electric field, and
will eventually collide with another atom.
That collision might knock another electron
loose. Now there will be two electrons accelerating.
A single electron can thus create a chain
reaction, where many atoms lose their electrons.
This creates a region of ionized air. Air
is normally a good insulator, but the presence
of ions allows it to conduct electricity.
...resulting in a lightning bolt!
Let's use the electric field and electric
potential to investigate this situation further.
Here are the Van de Graaff generators from
the video, charged up, with a metal ball as
a target.
Let's take a simplified version of the situation
shown. Draw the equipotential surfaces around
these two objects, and then draw in the electric
field arrows as well. You can ignore the presence
of the support pillars.
Here are two hints. First, the small metal
ball is grounded, or "earthed," with an electrical
potential of zero. Second, the electrical
charge on the generator will spread itself
equally over the surface of the conducting
spheres.
Pause the video here to draw the equipotential
lines and the field vectors.
Here's another picture of the generator with
the target ball nearby.
This picture is too complex. Let's create
a simpler version of the picture. That's
Now we can draw in the lines. Our equipotential
lines will "hug" the surface of the conductors
when they are nearby. Because the charge is
spread evenly across the surface of the conductor,
the whole surface will be at the same electric
potential. The equipotential lines will tend
to be smoother when farther away from the
conductors.
Because the electric potential of the Van
de Graaff generator gets up to about one million
volts (or 1000 kilovolts), and we have drawn
eight lines in the picture, each line must
represent a difference of about 125 kilovolts.
In this view we have colored in the regions
where the equipotential lines are more closely
packed, or less closely packed.
In the blue area, with the close-packed lines,
the gradient of the potential is larger. Because
the electric field is proportional to the
gradient of the potential, the places where
our lines are more closely packed will have
a stronger electric field.
In the red areas, where equipotential lines
are far apart, the gradient of the potential
is smaller. Therefore, the electric field
will be weaker.
We can use this as a guide when drawing our
field vectors.
Let's draw in those electric field vectors
now. We have assumed here that the generator
becomes positively charged, but if it were
negatively charged, we could simply reverse
the direction of our arrows.
Look carefully: our field arrows are perpendicular
to the equipotential surfaces at all points.
Check your own diagram - is this true on yours
as well?
Our field arrows are longer where the equipotential
lines are more closely packed—is this true
on your diagram?
If you need to revise your diagram or draw
a new one, do so now. If you have questions
for your teacher, here is a chance to ask
them.
Pause the video here.
Some of you may be confused by the terminology
that is used for this phenomenon. Many people
refer to the "breakdown potential" required
to create a spark. However, but you may have
noticed that the sparks in the video were
produced where the electric field was the
strongest, not where the electric potential
was the highest. Turn to a friend and discuss
why this is the case. Pause the video here
to discuss.
If we return to the equations that relate
the field and the potential, we can improve
our understanding. You can see that we have
a gradient term—a derivative with respect
to distance.
If our potential changes slowly over distance,
the field is weak, and no spark is generated.
On the other hand, if the potential changes
quickly over distance, the field is strong.
A stronger field is more likely to remove
an electron from an atom.
In fact, when numerical values are given for
the breakdown potential, they are most often
given in "volts per meter," which is a measurement
of the electric field. The term "breakdown
potential" is a little misleading, but it
is still the standard terminology.
To review, the gradient connects the electric
field to the electric potential. A steeper
change in the potential results in a stronger
electric field. We also saw that electrical
breakdowns happen in areas of strong electric
field, or of steep change in electrical potential.
We hope you enjoyed this clip from the Theatre
of Electricity at the Boston Museum of Science.
Good luck in your future studies of electricity.